yes
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here so the samsung
galaxy s 21
is
200
cheaper than last year
that's a big deal we're so used to the
prices of phones going up and up and up
year after year that when you do see a
big jump down in price
it's because there was a conscious
decision made here to offer more value
so basically every smartphone that's not
the highest end thing they can make
is fundamentally a balancing act
to try to check just the right set of
boxes and combine just the right set of
features to appeal to the most buyers
and that's especially if you're samsung
because they've got this goal to be the
default smartphone to keep their top
spot top of mind but the customer is
more educated than ever and so no
pressure or anything but you got to
check the right side of boxes or they'll
switch on you
so the galaxy s21 they've dropped this
year i think checks all the most
important boxes most people care about
performance
battery camera and the smart sacrifices
they've made to get to drop the price by
200 bucks
almost no one will notice
will you so first of all let's just
start with the big one the design i've
said i think is nice it's actually grown
on me i started with like i don't really
hate it and then it went somewhere up to
i kind of like it and now i think it's
one of the best honestly if you're going
to have a camera bump own it this phone
looks good in gray looks even better in
this purple and gold teddy fresh
contrast combo and looks even better in
an icon skin linked below of course but
generally like i said in my s21 ultra
review this purposeful design bringing
the metal camera bump straight to the
sides where it wraps around the rails
that's nice that's nice that's a good
call but this camera little plate here
is the only piece of metal on the back
of the phone the rest
is plastic
and you'd barely notice it's still
coated in the same way with this like
super fine smoothish texture
still has the same sheen to it it is
lighter when you're holding it than the
glass phones the s21 plus and the s21
ultra but to be honest i'm way more
focused on the smaller footprint than
the weight this goes all the way down to
a 6.2 inch display so you'd expect it to
be decently light anyway and 6.2 inches
by the way still plenty of screen it's a
little bit smaller but it is a pretty
big screen so the plastic definitely not
something you immediately feel and go oh
they did a bad job you'll barely notice
so let's talk about that screen so
there's a couple things going on here
it's still a really great samsung
display it's very bright and readable
outdoors has great color and hdr cert
it's perfectly flat even flatter at the
edges than the slightly curved s21 ultra
so i like this flatness a lot on this
colorway you do get a little bit of the
gold rails kind of peeking around the
sides which can make it look a little
bit cheaper ideally it's just like thin
black bezels and then nothing that would
look sleek but overall great display
same great larger ultrasonic fingerprint
reader as the ultra same size tiny
selfie camera cut out even though it's a
different selfie camera
and there's no way you notice from
watching this youtube video
but
they dropped the resolution
from 1440p to 1080p but the reason most
people won't notice is one it's still a
pretty sharp display 1080p on 6.2 inches
is up over 400 pixels per inch it's not
like a bad pixel density but two
last year in order to switch to 120
hertz you had to use the screen at 1080p
and so you couldn't use 1440p and 120hz
at the same time and that was kind of a
bummer but samsung i guess ran the
numbers did the research understood that
most people liked the 120 hertz and
would take 1080p for that every time
so now we do is 1080p every time and
it's 120 hertz now would it have been
better if we could use both like we can
on the ultra
yeah
but will most people even notice
i don't think so there's also a couple
of even smaller things missing no s pen
support on the regular s21 like the
ultra gat and the variable refresh rate
goes from 48 hertz to 120 hertz instead
of 10 to 120 hertz so very small
differences that samsung has weighed
against how much money they can save and
whether people will notice or not i
absolutely did not notice any difference
in responsiveness or performance this
phone has been a great performer and
speaking of performance honestly this is
the one area where they still did go
super high end this phone has the same
chip the snapdragon triple eight in this
region and it's every bit as much of a
performer as it is on the ultra it does
have eight gigs of ram instead of 12 or
16 but i never found i noticed any
hesitation or performance or worse
multitasking where i was wishing i had
all that ram back now they could have
they could have gone with a lower end
chip this the 7 series they could have
put a snapdragon 765 g in this phone
like a lot of others have in their
phones at this price
and it would have been yet another
savings they could have made that we
probably wouldn't have really
noticed actively as a difference in
performance
but they didn't this is still the
fastest chip in a phone so i really do
appreciate that all the same
capabilities from the ultra as far as
software enabled by the chip they're all
still here and i didn't notice a
difference in ram i used it just like i
used the ultra and i had no problems
with lag or choppiness at all so
throughout all of samsung's absolutely
packed software you know the dozens of
embedded one ui features and maximum
customization it's definitely nice to
have a smaller phone that still performs
almost exactly like the bigger phone now
these cameras on the back they're
another area where you of course see a
difference between this and the ultra
the ultra we already knew was all about
giving you the big numbers the ultra
camera experience that's the focus of
this phone
on this phone i think they've done a
great job balancing taking the features
out of the ultra
that most people probably won't need or
even notice and there's actually one
thing
one thing that this phone does on
cameras better than the ultra
might not have known that see if you can
guess that go ahead and pause this video
go ahead and write down what you think
this camera might do better than the
ultra and then hit play we'll see if you
were right so there's triple cameras on
the back of the s21 and they are
essentially the same cameras from the
s20 the main camera there's an ultra
wide and a 3x telephoto so no crazy 100x
space zoom just a reasonable maximum of
30x but at the end of the day if you
don't do a ton of huge zooms and you
still have the same sort of zoom lock
where you can zoom all the way into the
end of the camera and it'll stabilize
the software that's probably about as
good as most people will need it's not
quite as sharp at that range as the
ultra but will you notice there's no
laser autofocus here either although i
found with the smaller sensor it still
has no focus issues and then there's the
same snapdragon triple 8 so all the same
capabilities like single take mode 8k
video the director's mode all that stuff
is still here
so what does it do better than the ultra
well the one thing with the word ultra
in it is the ultra wide camera here on
the s21 it's actually a little bit wider
than the ultra wide on the ultra you can
see it labels it 0.5 x versus 0.6 x but
it's a little noticeably wider actually
didn't notice it before checking the
numbers it's great also i just want to
shout out samsung's portrait mode for
getting consistently better and better
over time this will be my hot take for
this video but i think samsung's
portrait mode is now the best portrait
mode in any smartphone put it over the
iphone put it over the pixel
seriously impressive stuff so don't let
the lack of holes in the back of the
camera fool you this is still a very
capable camera system the lack of laser
autofocus the lack of zoom past 30x the
lack of a macro mode built in
i noticed them because i'm a camera nerd
but
most people won't actually miss that
stuff it's a great camera and there's a
couple other small things here there's a
4 000 milliamp hour battery which is of
course a bit smaller than the 5 000
milliamp hours on the bigger one yes but
it's still a big battery and it lasted
all day getting five plus hours of
screen on time no problem i i could kill
it in a day if i'm hammering it all day
with a lot of gps and a lot of screen on
time but aside from that it's fine it's
a no worry battery
and there's no expandable storage but
that's also gone from the entire lineup
and so is mst which was this cool trick
that let samsung phones use magnetic
pulses to replicate credit card
functionality so they could pay with
stuff at terminals that don't support
nfc some people are going to hate that
this is gone
but that's another bet samsung had to
make that most people weren't using it
those are like the two most sorely
missed features for me and a lot of
enthusiasts expandable storage and mst
was super useful but
the whole line dropped by 200
so there's gonna be stuff that they cut
out and that's the calculus they made is
okay that's not getting a whole ton of
use we'll get those but at the end of
the day i think samsung checked the
right set of boxes with the s21 and it's
also only 50 bucks to upgrade and double
the storage to 256 gigs which is pretty
important since you no longer have
expandable storage and if you're taking
lots of photos and 8k videos you might
want that so that's another great
calculus to make but overall this is no
doubt the best bang for the buck in the
lineup i think it's going to be super
common early to compare the s21 to the
ultra which is a lot of what i did in
this video but this phone costs four
hundred dollars more
so when you compare this phone up
against this competition which is a
bunch of other phones sitting around six
seven eight hundred bucks it's gonna
compare pretty favorably it's gonna have
the highest end chip it's gonna have one
of the nicest screens great fingerprint
reader great camera system and the stuff
that's missing which is the stuff that
samsung is hoping you probably won't
care too much about or even notice
i think they made the right calculations
on so this is it this is the standard
package
i have no problem recommending this
phone but i'm also very curious to see
how the rest of the competition will be
attacking s21 all year for the rest of
2021. it'll be fun
either way that's been it definitely
watch the s21 ultra video right by that
like button if you haven't seen it
already
uh and that's that's pretty much it i'll
catch you guys in the very next video
see you later peace
[Music]